[Music]
[Applause]
he's a dad I think his son is going to
be two months old coming up tomorrow at
heart issues he made some money with
some sacks against the Broncos a lot of
things always great to have J.J watt
joining us how difficult is it now when
you leave the house and you got your
two-month-old baby there at home that
you have to say goodbye to
uh it's very very difficult but I it's a
whole lot better to come home every
night like after I mean after a tough
loss after a tough road trip uh it's
just
normally you know I'm in a real bad mood
I'm like down but I still am but then I
come home and it kind of just melts away
all you gotta do is see that face he
doesn't know how your day went that's
always great there
um exactly did you get you get uh drug
tested after the the loss against Denver
uh yes I did okay how does that work
how does how does which part of it on
which part of it works well I understand
what you have to do for the drug test
I'm talking about so right after right
after the game and then you go into
locker room and then what happens
no no so I got a text the next morning
like Monday morning I got a text saying
you got selected for drug testing please
show up at uh the drug testing area and
then you have like a three hour window
where you have to go show up
is that a compliment that you're getting
drug tested
I don't know it always seems to pop up
after the after a three-sack game so I
uh I'll take it as a compliment I don't
mind I mean it's it's a slight
inconvenience in my day but I mean it
doesn't matter to me like I'll I'm gonna
pee anyway
and then tell me about these incentive
uh bonuses that you got are you aware
that you're making money with these
sacks that you had in the first half
this is actually fine so uh when I
signed my contract down here I knew I
had incentives in it
um but I was on I was I thought that uh
when I got hurt last year I missed last
year's incentives I thought that took
away my incentives from this year
so my dad just like literally two weeks
ago was down here in Arizona and he
asked me he was like hey you're getting
close to your incentives right and I was
like oh no like I I don't those got
wiped out because last year he goes oh
darn so then fast forward to the game
after the game I see all these tweets
they're saying like JJ Watt made nine
hundred thousand dollars today and my
dad texted me he's like hey I'm seeing
all this stuff are you sure you don't
have it and I'm like yeah no it sucks
and and then I see more tweets so I'm
like all right let me call my agent real
quick so I call my agent and I'm like
hey I I see all these tweets man like my
dad's asking me people are asking my
brothers are asking me and he's like oh
yeah it's real and I'm like what he's
like yeah we don't like to tell you as
you get close to Milestones because we
don't want you to have it in your head
and like get get in your head about it
but yeah you made 900 Grand today I was
like oh it's a pretty nice Christmas
present but then if you get to 10 sacks
this season
that's is that another million dollars
uh I don't think it's another million I
think it's just a million total oh
because I don't know I I still have not
I still have not sat down there like I
actually looked at it I do not know
let me ask your wife to look at it I I
have I have something that says you're
playing for another incentive a 10 sack
season we'll give him an extra one
million dollars
well that would be nice that would be
nice
we're talking to J.J watt the older
brother of TJ watt joining us on the
program
[Music]
how's your brother doing
he's doing good wait that was meant to
be a joke that you were
you were producing you as TJ Watts older
brother that was supposed to elicit
maybe a giggle
I'm used to it by now then you can't
give me any more I uh we we flipped
rolls uh I am now his brother even
though uh I I had to give him a little
[ __ ] yesterday because he he's a pro
bowl starter and uh I have more sacks to
him this year so
uh just gave him a jab do players want
to go to the Pro Bowl
I don't even know what it is
here I it's not a game anymore right so
some some form of
skills competition
um
you know when I first went to the Pro
Bowl
it was when like Peyton Manning was kind
of running the show out there yep and so
you go to Hawaii and you have the
welcome meeting and it would be I mean
for me I was a young guy and it was
Peyton Manning Adrian Peterson all these
like guys that I literally looked up to
and Peyton was telling stories and then
you'd go hang out by the pool pool bar
and everybody's having a drink and
sharing these unbelievable stories and I
just sat there kind of wide-eyed I do
think it has changed from that a little
bit especially with it being not at in
Hawaii anymore because once you were
there everybody was kind of at one
Resort and there wasn't much else to do
outside of it you just everybody hung
out there and just kind of spent time
with each other I do think it's
different now that it's here and it's at
Vegas and there's so much to do
Arizona's lost four in a row you got
Tampa Bay coming up on Sunday night how
many times you sacked Brady
once in the playoffs hmm
yeah he used to fall off so fast it's
incredible I mean he's he's brilliant
obviously he knows he knows every
defense he sees everything before the
snap he knows where he wants to go to
the go with the ball I mean he don't
play until you're 45 years old without
finding a way to not take too many hits
and he does an incredible job of that so
uh every time I play him it's a great
challenge of trying to find a way to get
back there before he gets out of his
hand you saw where uh the defensive back
uh Drake Greenlaw a linebacker asked for
an autograph from Brady after he
intercepted him would you would you swap
jerseys with Brady after this game
I there's not many people I would do
that with um I would I would certainly
do it with the greatest player of all
time I do not see that happening I don't
I'm not that guy I don't really ask for
him and I have a feeling Tom is not that
guy either so I don't think either of us
are going to be walking up to each other
asking for the other Jersey
um give me give me an update on the
heart situation I mean it seemed kind of
scary there uh I'm sure it was for you
but where do where do things stand now
yeah fortunately I'm in a situation
where I don't think about it very often
it was extremely scary when it happened
um we ran obviously a multitude of tests
I mean everything from all your heart
tests your blood tests I did a sleep
study I did everything and uh
it basically I was told that it could
happen again tomorrow it could not
happen again for 20 more years we really
don't know
but I'm not really
at risk so I checked my I check my pulse
multiple times a day I just make sure my
heart's beating and Rhythm multiple
times a day and I kind of just go about
my life
when did you know something was wrong
um it was after so it was it was not
Thursday and after practice on that
Thursday I got my lift in and then after
the lift we had meetings and I was in
the meetings and
when I stood up I got kind of
lightheaded and I could feel like my
heart like my chest kind of beating
differently like it was it just felt
like fluttering and it felt like it
wasn't beating properly so I checked my
own pulse
and my heart was definitely not beating
in sync you know your car is normally
boom boom boom boom I was kind of going
more
oh
boom boom boom and so freaked me out so
I went in and asked the trainers what uh
could you guys just checked me out I
think my heart's doing something weird
and when they listen to my heart I saw
them look on their face and I was like
all right this clearly isn't good so
then they sent me to our team doctor he
checked my heart the same look on his
face so he I was like all right this is
really bad and then he sent me to the
cardiologist who then he sent me to
somebody else and when the cardiologist
sends you to somebody else that's when
you get a little freaked out and uh
eventually we got it all figured out but
it was definitely an extremely scary
couple days yeah I can only imagine you
know that what is it and then you got to
go home and tell your wife and then
you're trying to figure out can I still
play football
uh he had a baby on the way at the time
that's a whole lot to process
yeah no there was a lot being processed
in a short amount of time uh and then
somehow we were just I mean I still like
I partially don't want to look stuff up
about it because I don't want to know
but then I also really do because I need
to know I mean when they told me I was
trying to practice and play the next day
I was like I mean I trust doctors a
whole lot more than myself I'm not the
smartest dude on the planet so they went
to school a lot longer than I did how
would you have done with uh nil when you
went to Central Michigan
I probably wouldn't have done too well
because I don't think I would have made
any money so it would have been about
the exact same
I mean I don't know I don't think they
were paying paying a whole lot for uh
whatever star no star two star guy I was
so probably would have been very similar
maybe maybe your last year at Wisconsin
you would have cashed in
I honestly do actually believe that like
that is where it could have played a
factor because
your Junior possibly leaving for your
senior year you absolutely love the
school that you're at you really I mean
for us we lost the Rose Bowl and you
feel like you have some unfinished
business and things you want to do
um but the reality of the situation is
there's an opportunity to set your
family up for a very long time yeah it's
hard to say that if somebody you know
back then was like hey we got a million
dollars for you I mean as a as a 22 year
old kid a million dollars is I mean
that's anybody a million dollars is
unbelievable and you don't necessarily
think well
it could be you know 15 million dollars
in the NFL you're just thinking about
right in front of you so I do think that
would have put more questions into my
head
um but I also think man
think when you were in college like if
you gave me a million dollars when I was
in college
it is unbelievable to think about what
the hell would have happened what would
you have done with a million dollars at
Wisconsin
but we have a group chat with my buddies
and my brothers and uh also high school
and so we we did this exercise the other
day and the first thing I would do is I
would pre-pay like five grand parking
tickets
um because the parking is such a problem
I mean I was getting towed I was getting
tickets left and right so I would just
go to the Madison parking police and say
here
um guess what you're gonna see my
scooter everywhere that's fine just mark
it on my tab
then there would probably be a pretty
large party for my teammates and I on
State Street somewhere
um tabs on me boys and then uh I would
have a cool apartment I think that's
just I think as a college kid you know I
mean I was I was living in some spots
Dan I was living in some spots
it wasn't exactly a penthouse so I might
have myself you know something
overlooking the water there in Madison
well congrats on the baby and hopefully
it's a great Christmas for everybody and
good luck against Brady and check in on
that if you get enough if you get to 10
sacks do you make another million
dollars
yeah I will check in on that actually
I'm going to check on that today I
appreciate it happy to be here with a
bunch of good ass dudes today
because that's what we do we're good ass
dudes
I pay my parking tickets I pay my
parking tickets we're good ass dudes
great to hear from you thank you buddy
all right guys have a good one all right
all right he went there that was awesome
I'm glad he went there
good ass dude